[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter theory in
this video we're going to be discussing
the three unforgivable curses and their
relationship to Severus Snape spell
Sectumsempra didn't Sectumsempra
nearly killed Malfoy in the half-blood
Prince and wasn't it Sectumsempra that
caused George Weasley to lose an ear
it's definitely quite a sinister spell
but is it unforgivable
before we get started let's have a brief
look at what the three unforgivable
curses are a quote from Alastor Moody in
Chapter 14 of the Goblet of Fire reads
as follows
now those three curses Avada Kedavra
imperious and crew see artists are known
as the unforgivable curses the use of
any one of them on a fellow human being
is enough to earn a life sentence in
Azkaban that's what you're up against
that's what I've got to teach you to
fight you need preparing you need arming
but most of all you need to practice
constant never ceasing vigilance this
quote of course is actually by Barty
Crouch jr. the unforgivable curses are
widely considered to be three of the
most powerful and sinister spells known
to the Wizarding World they have the
tools of the dark arts and generally
only used by the darkest and most
sadistic witches and wizards the
Imperius curse or imperio when cast on a
victim forces them to perform the
unquestioned bidding of the caster the
Cruciatus curse or crucio when cast on a
victim inflicts excruciating pain pain
so excruciating that it is considered to
be torturous the third unforgivable
curse is Avada Kedavra or the killing
curse which when cast on a victim does
just that it kills them so all of these
spells
seem pretty awful that's fair to say but
Sectumsempra isn't such a wonderful
spell itself we first see Sectumsempra
in the films when harry uses it on
Malfoy in the half-blood Prince
Sectumsempra is a vicious dark curse
that acts like an invisible sword
causing lacerations hemorrhaging and
cuts upon its target often after being
struck the target will lay there
motionless as they lose blood it is
somewhat of a specialty of Snape's and
is featured in his half but prints copy
of advanced potion making
the three unforgivable curses are widely
considered to be unforgivable because of
their sadistic nature but what else
makes them unforgivable
first of all legislation plays a part in
their classification these spells have
been around for a very very long time
and they weren't classified as
unforgivable and illegal by the Ministry
of Magic until the year 1717 what
prompted the ministry to eventually
classified them as unforgivable is
unknown though there must have been some
sort of catalyst
Sectumsempra was independently created
by Snape and it wasn't even created
until the year 1977 260 years after the
original unforgivable curses were
classified as unforgivable the original
unforgivable curses were thought to have
been created by dark Wizards sometime
between the fifth and 15th century so
they had a lot of time to build up the
reputation that they had barely anyone
even knew about Snape spell so it's
highly improbable that it would be
noticed by the Ministry and then grouped
with the standing unforgivable curses
one other thing that sets the spell
apart is intent there is no gray area
with unforgivable curses the Imperius
curse controls the killing cursed kills
and a cushy artists curse tortures in
order to successfully cast one of the
unforgivable curses you need to
understand it properly and you need to
want to cast it you have to want to kill
torture or control this person in the
order of the Phoenix Harry attempts to
use crucio on Bellatrix but is
unsuccessful she then says to Harry
never used an unforgivable curse before
have you boy she yelled she had
abandoned her baby voice now you need to
mean them Potter you need to really want
to cause pain to enjoy it righteous
anger won't hurt me for long I'll show
you how it's done
shall I I'll give you a lesson
Sectumsempra is very different it
doesn't require this same level of
intent or deep understanding when Harry
first reads about Sectumsempra in
Snape's copy of advanced potion making
he is able to fully car Sectumsempra
almost immediately and in a panic
without understanding any of its effects
to boot the amount of damage that
Sectumsempra causes is all
not particularly straightforward and I
would imagine that the cuts and
lacerations or damage that it causes
overall varies to a degree this is very
much unlike the unforgivable curses that
are very black and white in terms of
their efficacy it's all quite ambiguous
another reason for its not being
unforgivable is that it has a
counterspell the treatment for
Sectumsempra is vulnera sanentur which
was also invented by Snape though the
spell is highly dangerous and
potentially lethal it's just not
unforgiveable and that's it for this
video
if you guys enjoy the content please
remember to like the video and subscribe
to the channel until next time you're a
wizard Harry
[Music]